психологічно я не могла дихати я просто
не могла дихати Я забувала їсти забивала
що дітей треба готувати для мене оці
перші три місяці було От я не пам'ятаю
що я робила щось робила Що я зараз піду
духом що буде з моєю дитиною як би це не
було важко але це так і є
тому що
[музика]
цих українок об'єднують різні втрати
рідних житла роботи і загалом колишнього
мирного життя усе це забрала в них війна
тепер вони вчаться заново долати
труднощі та опікуватися дітьми попри
невідомість майбутнього Доброго ранку
син цілую обнімаю тебе такими відео
Володимир щоранку вітав шестирічного
сина бодюс з фронту Доброго ранку
сарделька Дивись як треба
та найбільше Бодя любить ось цю
колискову під гітару яку тато зіграв на
відео з Харківщини Спи маленький козачок
[музика]
повернися на бочок
баю-бай прийде завтра Миколай
усі ці численні відео цінні спогади
чотирьох дітей Володимира про їхнього
тата Минулого року він посмертно отримав
звання героя України за захист
Харківщини де загинув рятуючи побратимів
дружина Галина не може описати Як жила
перші три місяці після звістки про
загибель коханого Я забувала їсти
забувала що дітей треба готувати для
мене оці перші три місяці було От я не
пам'ятаю що я робила до туги за
чоловіком додалася відсутність роботи і
стрес у малечі відтепер Галина мусила
виховувати чотирьох дітей самотужки
Богдана ну сказали він там щось
перепитує навіть от через рік він а коли
він нас закінчиться точно тато не прийде
його ніяк не можна вилікувати
старші це вже розуміють
син замкнувся собі дочка щодня
психологічний стрес переживала і Галина
мала проблеми зі сном втім каже не
наважувалася звернутися по допомогу
фахівців доки подруга не порадила
волонтерський проект реабілітації Мені
подзвонили сказали це тобі треба Якщо що
я
спокійно і
врівноважена то і дітям легше
волонтери запросили Галину та її дітей
на проєкт реабілітації кемп плюс у
Карпатах
разом з психологами родина вчилася жити
заново готувати улюблені страви
танцювати ходити на прогулянки і головне
говорити про свій біль зі спеціалістами
[музика]
три тижні арт-терапії індивідуальних
консультацій та командних занять зараз
Галина та інші учасниці продовжують
займатися з фахівцями у Київському
центрі фонду голоси дітей сьогодні кожна
з них проговорює що її тривожить на
груповому сеансі терапії після обмена
начинают друзья Ну что-то Ну что там
какие у тебя новости Ну что там а мне и
так тяжело что мы можешь не попал в этот
обмен це Марія жінка що разом з
десятирічною донькою втратила рідну
домівку у Маріуполі та друзів яких в
окупації вбили росіяни та найгірше каже
Вона втрачено зв'язок з чоловіком що вже
понад рік перебуває у полоні після
оборони азовсталі життя в прямому сенсі
розділилася на дві половини
Останнє що Марія чула від свого чоловіка
телефоном перед його здачею в полон вона
повторює зі сльозами на очах
браке первое было фраза
Ирина Что Сейчас говорить
[музика]
тоді жінка ще не знала що вони
розлучаться надовго у місті тривали
вбивства цивільних на виїздах з
Маріуполя російські військові проводили
фільтрацію евакуюватися автівкою Було
неможливо Ми пішли пішка
невідомість у нас був будиночок перед
місць який залишився від бабусі потім
виїзд що
там з самого початку базувалися орки
саме його початку вони звідти стріляли
дитина важко бо коли виходили з міста
вона бачила
трупи вона бачила весь цей жах
психологічно я не могла дихати я просто
не могла дихати я не могла проходити
поруч після евакуації з Донеччини усе
пережити Марія наважилася вперше
розповісти психологу одна зі складових
терапії віднайти з фахівцем заняття що
мотивуватиме так Разом з донькою під час
групових сеансів на кемпі Марія
захопилася плетінням маску вальних сіток
для ЗСУ Ми живемо отаким якимось
принципом що
ми розповімо татові як ми його чекали що
в нас не було просто сплошних сльоз
любимо наших дівчаток каже моїм Дякую за
такі
подаруночки вони відправляють нам не
тільки свічки але і теплі речі
з гордістю відеоподяки від воїнів ЗСУ за
маскувальні сітки та окопні свічки
переглядає і Наталія завдяки
волонтерство вона також долає
посттравматичний синдром внаслідок
повномасштабної війни яку зустріла на
Луганщині торік чоловік 24 лютого 2022
пішов на фронт А вона з дитиною на руках
застала обстріл будинку з якого дивом
вийшла живою разом з малечею давайте
розумієш прийшли погані дяді поламали
Наш будинок поламали дві садочок Тато
зараз виганяє їх з нашої країни
сказати що вони прийшли на збивати Я
цього не могла
була така ситуація ми їхали з нею в
автобусі сидів військових в броніку
сумками вона здимені питання мам а він
їде на війну хоча приніс слово війна Я
ніколи не говорила
для мене От стан дитини
Це дуже важко
А коли вона таке питання він не вистачає
тата
вона тягнеться до всіх чоловіків
сьогодні з Наталією поруч немає
шестирічної донечки та постійно вдома у
тимчасовому житлі яке їм надали
благодійники дівчинка досі долає
наслідки стресу і боїться людних місць
через це під питанням її вступ до
першого класу школи коли ми виїхали вона
місяць взагалі мовчала вона не
розмовляла В неї були панічні так і в
той же час який їй Я тримаюся тому що я
розумію що якщо я зараз буду духом що
буде з моєю дитиною як би це не було
важко але це так і є
тому що
[музика]
Наталія публікує у соцмережах вірші зі
звертаннями і до українців і гнівно до
росіян
уже ненужний брак що ви от нас хотите на
свою землю обратно уходить так як
Наталія пройшли довгий шлях аби
проговорити свої історії і прийняти
власні емоції від пережитого розповідає
психотерапевтка у цьому і полягає
частина терапії Ми шукаємо їх ресурсів
ресурси у кожної людини
української жінки є ці ресурси але
просто вона розгубилась забула
розказуємо як
відбувається що таке стрес да
які чинники впливають на стрес що з нами
з нашим мозком відбувається коли ми
стресуємо які реакції нормальні у всіх
виключно людей які зараз в цьому році з
нами працюєте приїхали в кем невротичний
десь у 10%
птср усього психологічну реабілітацію у
цьому фонді пройшли понад 200 дітей та
180 дорослих найчастіше Люди приходять
на терапію тоді коли вже мають критичні
проблеми зі сном розлади харчування
апатію або панічні атаки у дітей
помітний регрес у розвитку були у нас
випадки коли діти наприклад розмовляли
да вони вже володіли
мовними апаратом Вони знали слова але
трапилась якась подія яка їх
відштовхнула там на півроку на рік в
минуле тобто дитина перестала розмовляти
фонд голоси дітей надає також
гуманітарну та правову допомогу дітям
їхнім матерям зокрема з оформленням
необхідних документів і пошуками нового
житла ми допомагали евакуюватися родинам
поселяли
працюємо за індивідуальним запитом ми
ніколи не жартизуємо дітей Ми показуємо
що українські діти стійкі талановиті
творчі але вони живуть у війні їм
потрібно допомога головне я кажу жінки
які взяли участь у проєкті це нове
відчуття внутрішньої сили його вони
отримали коли наважилися розповісти свої
історії фахівцям це не одна і
є хто тобі може допомогти ми один одного
підтримуємо мене розуміють люди які щось
не пережили і вони ну
не розуміють цього що ми переживаємо
Галина після втрати чоловіка повернулася
до роботи вона вихователька дитячого
садка її мрія створити власний освітній
хаб для дошкільнят у сина Боді мріє
стати таким як тато захис